REPORTS FOR US NOW, UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE ARE NOT GIVING UP WITHOUT
A FIGHT.
>> Reporter: THE TOWN OF KHERSON
REFUSES TO GIVE UP, IT SEEMS.
LOOTING CRIPPLING LIFE HERE,
THIS RUSSIAN SOLDIER'S BID TO
GET INTO A CELL PHONE STORE, A
SIGN OF THE LAWLESS WORLD THEY
BROUGHT WITH THEM, WHERE FOOD
AND MEDICINE IS LACKING.
AND WHAT LIFE IS LEFT MADE MORE
UNBEARABLE BY THE LAYING OF TRIP
WIRE MINES, LOCAL OFFICIALS
SAID.
THIS ONE POSTED ONLINE TO WARN
OTHERS.
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
RUSSIAN-HELD CRIMEA, MARIUPOL
UNDER SIEGE.
WITHOUT WATER OR ELECTRICITY,
THE MAYOR SAYING THE RUSSIAN,
QUOTE, SCUM HAVE FOUND NO OTHER
WAY TO BREAK US.
THE PRIZE IN THE SOUTH IS THIS,
ODESA.
ITS OPERA HOUSE FORTIFIED, ITS
COASTLINE A HARDER TASK.
WHERE THE TIDE COULD BRING
RUSSIANS IN WITH IT, YET STILL
LAPS AS IF NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
AN ESTONIAN SHIP SANK, ITS CREW
RESCUED WITH UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS
ACCUSING RUSSIA OF SHELLING IT
TO ACT AS COVER FOR THEIR
LANDING SHIPS.
ANY HOUR NOW WHEN THE LANDING
FORCE COULD COME INTO VIEW.
ODESA BRIMS WITH LOCALS READY,
THOUGH.
LIKE SO MANY HERE, THESE
CIVILIAN DEFENDERS DON'T WANT
THEIR WHEREABOUTS FILMED BUT ARE
HAPPY TO SPEAK.
THIS IS THE CHIEF MARKETING
OFFICER FOR AN I.T. COMPANY
WHO'S TRAVELED EUROPE AND AFRICA
BUT JOINED UP TO FIGHT ON DAY
ONE.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, I HAVE LOST
TWO OF MY FRIENDS IN KHERSON TWO
DAYS AGO.
>> Reporter: I'M SORRY.
WERE THEY FIGHTING?
>> YEAH, THEY WERE FIGHTING AND
THEY WERE IN VOLUNTEER TROOP SO
THEY HAVE NO MILITARY BACKGROUND
AT ALL.
BOTH OF THEM ARE PROGRAMMERS.
>> Reporter: WE'RE JOINED BY
LIRA, AGE 19, A NANNY WHO FLED
RUSSIANS IN CRYIMEA WHEN SHE WA
11.
WE'RE READY TO THE END TO DEFEND
OUR LAND, SHE SAID.
THE OCCUPIERS CAME TO MY LAND
BEFORE.
MY FAMILY IS STILL THERE.
ONLY I COULD LEAVE BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO LIVE IN RUSSIA.
ACROSS TOWN, MOTHERS KNIT
CAMOUFLAGE NETTING WHILE THEIR
DAUGHTERS FIGHT.
HERS STAYING BEHIND TO DEFEND
KYIV.
>> WE KNOW THE DANGER.
WE KNOW THAT IT WILL COME, BUT
WE DIDN'T KNOW WHEN WILL IT
COME.
AND I ASK THEM, CHILDREN, COME
HERE, PLEASE, BE SAFE.
COME TO ME BUT THEY DIDN'T WANT.
NO, MOM, PLEASE STAY ALIVE, STAY
SAFE, BUT WE WILL DEFEND BECAUSE
EVERYBODY LOVES OUR MOTHERLAND.
EVERYBODY.
SORRY.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE
INDEPENDENT, TO BE FREE.
THEY DECIDED TO STAY THERE AND I
CAN'T INFLUENCE THEIR DECISION,
BUT I PRAY EVERY DAY.
I PRAY EVERY NIGHT FOR THEM TO
STAY ALIVE.
>> Reporter: THE DEFIANT WORDS
OF THE UKRAINIAN SOLDIER OF
SNAKE ISLAND WHO TOLD A RUSSIAN
SHIP WHERE TO SHOVE IT ECHOED
HERE.
>> RUSSIAN SHIP [ BLEEP ].
IT'S THE LOGO NOW IN UKRAINE.
>> Reporter: THEY'LL NEED MORE
THAN HIGH SPIRITS IN THE DAYS
AHEAD.
AS THE NIGHTS GO BY HERE, WE
JUST CONSTANTLY HEAR OF SHELLING
ON THE OUTSKIRTS OF THIS TOWN.
IT HAS BEEN QUIET TONIGHT SO
FAR, JAKE.
SIRENS LAST NIGHT, BUT STILL A
PERSISTENT FEAR THAT WE ARE
SLOWLY SEEING RUSSIAN FORCES
MOVING IN TOWARDS THIS PRIZED
PORT CITY, JAKE.
>> NICK, THERE'S A MAYOR IN
CENTRAL UKRAINE, YOU'RE IN SOUTH
UKRAINE.
THERE'S ONE IN CENTRAL UKRAINE
WHO'S SAYING HE'S SEEING MORE
SHELLING THERE TONIGHT.
HE ALSO SAID AN ENEMY CONVOY IS
HEADED FOR A NUCLEAR POWER PLANT
IN HIS TOWN.
HAS INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH AS THIS
BECOME AN INCREASING TARGET OF
THE RUSSIAN FORCES?
>> Reporter: THIS IS WHAT YOU
ESSENTIALLY HAVE TO ASK, JAKE.
WHAT IS THE GOAL OF THIS RUSSIAN
MILITARY OPERATION IF IT IS NOT
JUST ESSENTIALLY DESTROYING
WHATEVER IT CAN.
IN THE CENTER OF THE COUNTRY, A
SEEN OF SERIOUS PROTEST AMONGST
LOCALS WHO WERE SIMPLY GETTING
IN THE WAY OF MILITARY CONVOYS
MOVING IN TOWARDS ITS CENTER.
WHY IS IT IMPORTANT?
WELL, IT CONTAINS PROBABLY THE
BIGGEST NUCLEAR POWER PLANT IN
EUROPE AND IT'S CURRENTLY UNDER
THREAT.
THERE ARE DEEP CONCERNS THAT
RUSSIAN CONVOYS MOVING TOWARDS
THAT PARTICULAR PLANT.
AND WE'VE SEEN THAT I WOULDN'T
SAY A WANTON APPETITE BUT THEIR
UTTER DISREGARD FOR LEAVING
INFRASTRUCTURE REMOTELY INTACT,
OFTEN TARGETING SPECIFICALLY
AGAINST THE CLAIMS OF RUSSIAN
OFFICIALS THAT IS NOT SOMETHING
THEY WOULD DO.
SO WHEN WE START SEEING RUSSIAN
FORCES HAVING MOVED NEAR THE
FORMER PLACES OF CHERNOBYL IN
THE PAST AND NOW SEEING THE
MOVEMENT AROUND AND THE COMMENTS
OF VLADIMIR PUTIN, THERE ARE
DEEP CONCERNS THAT WE ARE SEEING
A FORCE THAT HAS ABSOLUTELY NO
INTEREST IN ENSURING IT DOESN'T
CAUSE THE MOST AMOUNT OF
DESTRUCTION POSSIBLE, JAKE.
>> NICK, UKRAINIANS CONTINUE TO
FIGHT AGAINST THE RUSSIAN
TROOPS.
YOU'RE A LONG-TIME WAR
CORRESPONDENT.
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE HOW LONG
CAN THE UKRAINIANS KEEP IT UP?
ARE THEY GOING TO HAVE THE
RESOURCES AS LONG AS THEY NEED
THEM?
>> Reporter: THIS IS THE MOST
AWFUL PART OF ALL OF THIS, JAKE.
WE'RE SEEING JUST THE BEGINNING
HERE, THE FIRST WEEK.
YOU HEARD IN THAT REPORT SOMEONE
WHOSE TWO FRIENDS DIED JUST IN
THIS WEEK.
DO THEY HAVE THE RESOURCES?
PROBABLY NOT.
DO THEY HAVE THE WILL?
YES.
DOES THAT WILL MEAN THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT POSSIBLY WEEKS HERE
OF SLOW, GHASTLY, UGLY ATTRITION
AGAINST RUSSIAN FORCES?
YES.
HAVE WE SEEN THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY'S CAPACITY FOR
BRUTALITY, LACK OF DISCIPLINE,
LACK OF FOCUS?
YES, WE'VE SEEN IT IN THE PAST.
IF IT CONTINUES IN THIS
POTENTIALLY LENGTHY WAR OF
ATTRITION, IT WILL END BADLY FOR
UKRAINE AS WELL.
YOU JUST HAVE TO ASK WHAT HAS
ACTUALLY COME OVER THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT'S APPARENT GOAL IN
THEIR MIND OF SOME SORT OF
DEMILITARIZATION, THEY CALL